hey gang we free for a little rap
session do you want to go to the
conference room conference room is
booked I need to figure out how to book
the conference so what's up three weeks
ago I was entrusted with our company's
Twitter passcode that's right I beat out
everyone including stupid Larry in
Indianapolis and now the time has come
for my inaugural tweet wait why did you
wait three weeks well I lost the
passcode almost immediately so you want
to run it by us no I want you to help me
write it that's right the training
wheels are off kiddos welcome to the big
leagues that's a really big deal I mean
everyone's gonna remember our very first
tweet you think I don't know that
Elliott you think that hasn't kept me up
at night okay it doesn't have to be a
big deal how about welcome new followers
looking forward to serving you young I
need it to pop like the poop emoji oh
that's my favorite emoji sure that
that's great for a personal account but
we're professionals how about um excited
to be in the Twitterverse that was
pretty bad but I did like Twitterverse
yes that's good
let's work around that exploring the
Twitter I got an air B&B in the
Twitterverse those are popular okay I
think we're overthinking this a little
you know it's just a handshake keep it
simple
handshakes are the most complicated part
of my day focus Elliot Twitterverse we
don't wanna lose this hi
Mad Max and the Twitterverse welcome you
online okay you're just putting popular
things next to Twitterverse well when I
was in high school I used to try to sit
next to all the popular kids but it
didn't work for me I told you to stop
telling these stories like that Elliot
it makes me very upset I'm sorry me too
okay let's keep it simple
we're in the Twitterverse
well versed in the Twitterverse yes
perfect scent but it doesn't make sense
to those not well versed don't use both
hands so how do we do I'm getting a lot
of death threats I think the right thing
to do in this case is engage I would
advise against nap well you don't know
anything yet okay nope that was a penis
oh it's called a dick pic I think yeah I
am definitely missing a piece no I'm not
done because I'm missing a piece
you